what have you what have you enjoyed the
most of the of the movies that you've
made or what are the ones that you've
really feel like oh my god i loved
making that one you know yeah it's royal
tenenbaums like a really fun shoot or
some of them look great and it's an
amazing performance but
maybe it wasn't as easy to make well i
think yeah maybe the royal tenon bombs
just because
like you were saying rushmore was really
it was really fun to make and just happy
that owen and wes got to make another
movie because you know we thought bottle
rocket was it there was always kind of a
feeling of melancholy we were wait while
we were making it because we knew that
the studio didn't like it they didn't
like the dailies you know they always
they were always going to be sending
executives down to kind of monitor us
right so just the fact that those guys
got to make another movie and then you
know that they were able to get bill
murray
to act and it was really exciting so
then
you know on the tenon bombs just knowing
how much wes loved new york the fact
that he'd get to shoot in new york and
you know have gene hackman and i know
and angelica houston really start
putting people
in it um yeah that that for me was
probably the most exciting of those and
then really fun just to get to visit you
know
uh the life aquatic and get to see wes
shooting in
in europe and stuff like that but
in terms of the things that have been
the most fun to make
it's always kind of been with you know
funny people you know when i've gotten
to work with will
ferrell that's always been he's such a
good guy but also just a funny guy and a
hard worker
um that that's always kind of been the
most fun to me and exciting and i've
just yeah
you know growing up loving saturday
night live
and then getting to work with people
that were uh
that were in it i mean it to me it
always seemed like you know it's like
you have people that say oh i have a
friend that's a really funny guy and you
know there are those funny people you
meet and then you meet people like
you know yourself or will or it's like a
professional athlete where you think
like okay that's that's another level or
somebody like kristen wiig where
just um it's not just
you know that the takes and the work
you're doing it's just being around
people like that for you know for an
extended period of time is really really
fun and interesting one of the things
that uh
you made a really good point about will
ferrell
which is
he's a very hard worker
and he's so i think
uh disciplined
uh and has so much talent but he's also
a guy who's will go with the bit
you know what i mean he'll he'll he's
happy to mess around
and play and to me that was always
because they're really funny people that
uh
don't really love to play you know they
just they'll turn it on but then it
comes off and then there are people
like will you can
he'll start a bit you can start a bit
with him and it will just go
and he's having a good time and it's not
being recorded it's not for anybody it's
just to honor that moment of stupidity i
uh one time i'd run into will at the
at the u.s open tennis in new york and
will was with his
his kids at the time and one of his sons
was probably like six or seven and we
were sitting at kind of a high table
with like bar stools watching the tennis
and his kids were around and will was
saying he was kind of
worried they'd had like too many cokes
they were getting all kind of jacked up
and then at one point
they they had will and i on the on the
jumbotron talking and didn't know it and
his son came up to the table so his chin
is just kind of a table level he's like
dad dad and will turns and he points the
sun points to the jumbotron and will
looks at the jumbotron and wall looking
at it puts his hand on his son's face
and just pushes it
out of frame
and it's still one of the feminist
things and then the sun the little hands
it was still one of the funniest and
just like a physical thing not even a
not even a joke or a line
but it's still about the funniest thing
i've ever seen will do just a huge hand
on his face you know pushing him down
and out of the frame
while on the jumbo john
once i was on on on stage he was getting
an award it might have been the twain
prize i can't remember what it was but
he's getting some award and
um it's one of those awards where
a bunch of us who've been honoring him
or on stage or or uh and and he's there
giving his big speech and his
wife
is sitting up in the balcony you know
with his family and he just starts going
after her for getting a little mouthy
you know i remember that and it was f i
mean it was all a joke but he's like you
know i'm hearing a little lip from you
lady and it's i think it's the kennedy
center or something
and it was so funny because it was so he
was being so wildly inappropriate in a
comedic way and it was clearly a joke
but just fantastic and i thought no
one's ever done that at the kennedy
center told their wife to keep it down a
bit you know
sick of your lip